well good morning everyone welcome to my
talk
do I care first a little bit about me so
my name is Dave Beck Berger I am a
senior architect at a consulting company
called Xperia experience based out of
Texas in the United States we have and
we specialize in doing product discovery
UX design and architecture and
development for big data IOT and graph
databases myself I've been developing
software for about 18 years now most of
that time has been focused on developing
heavily in the.net stack but most
recently I've moved over to doing
completed pretty much back-end
development against graph databases been
doing that for about two years now if
you're interested in a little bit what
we do there's a couple of you know you
can go on to that page and take a look
at some of the things we do building on
top of graph databases specifically in
case anybody was wondering why I'm
walking around in a sling I explained
hockey on Sunday and decided to you know
hit the wall instead of a and I lost oh
but what are we going to talk about
today well today we're here to cover ah
we're going to do a little bit of an
introduction to what graphs are if
anybody here actually using a graph
database or has used a graph database in
the past which which one knio knio knio
okay so some of this will probably be
familiar to you guys then we're going to
talk a bit about some of the use cases
that graph databases are good at then
we're going to talk a bit about the
ecosystem so the ecosystem for graph
databases is changing literally every
day in fact yes I believe was yesterday
that Microsoft announced they'll mate
they now have a new graph processing
layer on top of sequel server so it's a
very fast growing area and then last why
you should care about it we know why not
just use your relational database well
should walk through a couple of examples
showing you just how graphs can help
simplify your life in some ways so
hopefully as I said hopefully you'll
walk out of here with you know you'll
know what a graph database does is an
isn't you know you know what you can you
know what you can do with them you have
an understanding of what the ecosystem
of graphs are graph databases are and
then what you can do to get
so first off we're going to walk through
a little bit of what I like to call it a
graph 101 for first you know we're not
talking about bar charts line charts
Park lines we're talking about
interconnect interconnected webs of data
so had any of you heard of the seven
bridges of königsberg problem I guess
probably a lot of people did at some
point but so basically the seven bridges
of königsberg problem laid down was
basically a famous problem that was
developed by a Leonardo Euler in 1736 he
was a swiss mathematician and this
became what basically this problem laid
down the foundations of what became
graph theory on which graph databases
are built basically there's you know
there was two islands and in the middle
of this river so there's four pieces of
land and seven bridges connecting them
and the problem was is it possible to
walk across every bridge once and only
once
this became what known as an oil Arian
walk if you can actually do this
excessively what oiler did was basically
he took this real world problem and was
able to extract it out into what you see
at the bottom here which is a the
abstract concept of nodes and edges you
know nodes and things are connecting
them together instead of curiosity does
anybody know if you can actually solve
this not yeah you're right you can you
can't annoy layering walk only works if
you have only love if you have a well
I'm sorry it doesn't work if you have
greater than two it two nodes that have
an odd number of edges of incident it's
just going into out and incident as
edges are edges coming into or out of a
node so first off what is a graph well a
graph is an ordered set of vertices and
edges and I promise it's the last time
I'm going to talk about anymore Matt
here's the rest of this topic
yeah you know vertices are basically a
finite set of elements and edges are a
basically a set of two subsets of
vertices so basically you know nodes or
vertexes are connected by edges it's
pretty straight forward the other way
you can think about this is it's an
entity and the relationship between them
or its vert when you're when you're f
you work
with these you tend to think of vertices
or the nouns and edges are the verbs in
your domain model so both vertices and
edges tend to have labels associated
with them you know in this case we have
two vertices which have the label of
person and the edge in between them is
labeled as Sun us they tend to connect
similar things so in this case we have
Jason who is the son of Alice so both
the vertices are people they can also
connect different things in this case
basically we have you know person lives
in a city so here Jason lives in Boston
they can connect different types of
things yet again you know here we have a
you know a spider-man lunchbox which is
part of the Marvel Universe it can
connect multiple different things at the
same time basically here we have you
know a spider-man lunchbox which is
connected into nut as which is part of a
franchise and is recommended for the age
groups 3 to 8 edges also tend to have
directions with them specifically when
we're talking about edges with
directions we're talking about directed
graphs which is a subset of graphs but
it's the type that got most graphs
databases are built upon so it's what
we're going to talk about in this talk
and as you can see here you know we have
our previous graph which had you know
spider-man launch box which was part of
the Marvel franchise and was recommended
for ages three to eight but now it also
has an inward facing edge from the
back-to-school promotion for 2015 ah and
what we're gonna talk about today both
vertices and edges may have properties
associated with them this is actually
one of the biggest differences between a
graph database and some say something
like a relational database in a
relational database
you know the relations between your
different entities themselves can't
really contain any metadata of their own
you know because in a relational
database the relations between your data
is basically foreign keys that's how you
know you know one one thing is related
to another you can't actually put
metadata on those foreign keys you end
up having to build a table in between
like something I like to call it or I
think of as a bridge table
um that to store any of that metadata
well in a graph database relationships
are first-class entities and those
entities are able to actually have that
metadata on that relationship itself and
it's one of the more powerful things I
find one actually working with graph
databases or migrating data from graph
from relational databases to graph
databases so what does a typical graph
query look like so find me all the
protein in this case we're going to look
at a simple a simple recommendation
query sort of use case in this case
we're going to want to find all the
products that are for the same
recommended age as a spider-man lunchbox
so what would you do the way you could
think about this is you'd start here at
the spider-man lunchbox and basically
you would walk out the recommended edge
to the age range of three to eight and
then you would look for any other
inward-facing edges that are also
recommended for that same age group in
this case there's only one which is the
Iron Man toothbrush when you're working
in graph what we just did is what's
actually uh you will be referred to as
the traversal of your graph that was a
very simple one but they get much more
complex than that you know one of the
things you know things that graph graphs
do very well is they're able to go
through an arbitrary number of hops in
order to in order to get two answers you
know so in this case we're basically
wanting to find all the products for
that are for the same recommended age
it's part of us the same or similar
franchise as that spider-man lunchbox in
this case we basically added somebody
added to the graph that you know the DC
Comics universe is a similar franchise
to the Marvel Universe so what would we
do here basically the way you would
Traverse for this graph or think about
how you would Traverse this graph is
first off you would Traverse the same
either graph the same way of going out
the recommended age you know to the age
range and then over to the Ironman
toothbrush to get that as one of the
responses back but you would also
basically at the same in parallel you
would actually Traverse out the part of
edge to the Marvel franchise you would
then Traverse out the similar edge to
the DC Comics franchise and then you
would reverse back the part of edge to
get the Superman
case so you would be in this case you
would turn the Superman pillowcase and
the Iron Man toothbrush but as you can
kind of see as we're walking through
this you know each one took a different
arbitrary path to get through there you
know and now someone has gone and adds
sales data to the graph so basically we
want to build a more powerful
recommendation engine based on items
that people bought well as you can see
if you wanted to solve you know I'm not
going to walk through this one cause
it's far more complex but you are able
to basically walk through a very large
arbitrary number of hops to get to that
same sort of information here if you
want to do something like this in a
relational database it basically would
probably require a lot of recursive
common table expressions unions joins
and it would be a query I would not want
to run or I would not want to write
maintain or probably try to play read
any performance increases on because it
would be a quite a headache to actually
get it to work within a reasonable
period of time
so I guess before we go on are there any
questions about what we talked about so
far
this one
yeah so the question here was in this in
this query would you get the Ironman
toothbrush twice depends on how you
actually put the query that you a lot of
these when you're querying these you
could actually you by default you would
probably get it twice but a lot of the
query languages allow you to remove
duplicates okay so next we're going to
talk a bit about some of the use cases
for graph databases so what are common
graph type problems so common graph type
problems are thing like dependencies you
know failure chains order of operations
needs something like this a lot of time
used for things like root cause analysis
we know order of operations I don't know
if any of you were in the talk with the
about terraforming console yesterday but
that was actually a great example of
basically finding dependency graphs you
know in order to build my infrastructure
I have to build the you know the V PC
before I can build a subnet that's part
of that V PC well that's a graph type
problem to do that you know clustering
finding things that are closely related
to each other um friends of friends you
know who hears on LinkedIn and gets be
like these are people you might know or
you know Facebook same sort of idea
that's you know would be a clustering
sort of problem or fraud fraud is
actually another very common use case
for graphs it you know the variety of
different algorithms but clustering is
one of them to basically say is this
group of transactions similar to another
you know clustered together with another
group of fraudulent are known fraudulent
track transactions similarity you know
similar pet you know you want to find
things that have similar paths or
patterns associated with them um you
know let's say you something like a
recruiter you know you work on
recruiting software and you want to take
AI you know from the position I'm at I
want to get to a CEO what other what is
the most common path or what is a very
similar path that's because people that
started like I have to get to become CEO
of a company you know matching our
categorization you know flow flow costs
like type problem
things like you know google maps are a
float off low-cost type problem I want
to find a shortest path from A to B
centrality and search problems you know
you want to find the most influential
person in a social network you know
another example of dependency type
problem is a pipeline you know what is
the root cause of a failure you know how
do i route flow from X to Y when I take
Y off line you know example vertices in
like a pipeline it would be something
like a storage tank a refinery or wells
edges would be pipelines control lines
things of that nature
industrial assets you know would be a
clustering sort of problem you know if
Part A fails what other parts tend to
fail with it you know I have a large
group of industrial maybe I run a
trucking fleet and if you know truck a
fails what other what other trucks tend
to fail with it with it you know and
then you can do you can go back and
actually do root cause analysis find out
why they may have failed together they
maybe they were all in the same place
that had a sandstorm at the same time or
something like that you know examples of
you know vertices in here things like
parts or assemblies or pieces of
equipment and edges are things like
consists of connected to is compatible
with similarity a you know an example of
similarity social networks and fraud
social networks are probably one of the
the most common use cases that people
think of with graphs you know LinkedIn
and Facebook made using graphs for a
social network a very common thing out
there anymore
you know which of my friends is the most
influential you know which of my users
activity or my users activities similar
to a known fraudulent pattern you know
here you would have vertices that are
things like people of business or
transactions
you know edges are things like phone
calls emails memberships purchases
categorization recommendation engine is
a very good example of a categorization
you maybe you want to you have a cat
different categories of people that you
want to do recommendations against you
know based on my history of buying of
purchasing products what am I likely to
purchase you know what type of customer
I when I am I when I use a system you
know here you have things like you know
vertices would be things like users or
orders or web pages if you're doing
something like clickstream tracking you
know edges would be things like
purchased or clicked it worked with
customers in this space where they
basically have click streams coming in
of applications and they want to be able
to basically categorize you into
different use cases are different groups
of users to basically show you something
like targeted advertising things of that
nature you know flow cost problems you
know transportation is the first one I
tend to think of here you know what is
the short stuff between x and y I don't
know about you guys but I've used Google
Maps since I've been here in London and
that's an example of how you actually
get from you know X to Y it's really it
has to do an unknown number of hops to
get from a you know from one place to
another you know they'll connect somehow
but you don't know how many you know
connections it will take to get there
while it's something you can do in a
relational database it's actually very
difficult to do unknown numbers or joins
you end up with recursive functions and
they tend to be very not are very
unperformed you know also things like
you know I'm going to take station X
offline for maintenance what's the
effect going to be on my you know
transportation network how's that how am
I going to route traffic around it what
are the different options you know here
you have vertices that are things like
stations or cities and edges of things
like railways roadways intersections
actually intersections I'm sorry would
be a vertice this case
centrality and search the internet the
Internet is nothing but a giant graph of
data this is actually where Google
really so for those of you that are old
enough to remember Alta Vista you know
Ultra Vista was based on basically just
searching the text inside your web
documents this is where Google actually
needs was differentiated from ulta this
and when they first came out as they
actually not only search the text inside
the document but they searched they
searched and indexed how those documents
were links to other documents they
basically built a graph of the web you
know but you know centrality and search
also useful for things like what are the
critical parts of my network you know
you know I'm storing network management
data or I'm storing data about how my
network is configured I want to find the
most critical piece of my infrastructure
you know if this router goes down half
of my network is going to go down
because it's the one single point of
failure inside my network that's a sort
of graph problem to solve you know here
you have things like you know your
vertices would be like routers or
computers your edged to be like you know
fibers or Ethernet connections microwave
connections case if you think about the
Google use case it would be things like
links of web pages really when you comes
down to it basically enter any
interaction out there you have as a
graph you know here's other sorts of
problems that you can solve with graphs
you know which professor publishes the
most influential paper maybe you have a
link of all you know papers published in
the last five years as well as all their
citations and you want to go out and
find which of those papers has been
cited the most either by that paper by
another paper that cited papers that
have cited it one we actually kind of
run across quite on quite often if
something like I have a user name to be
Smith I have a user named Brian Smith
maybe I'm a large maybe I work for a
large company and we have multiple
different ways in which a customer can
interact with him well I want to figure
out if those two people are the same
person in order to basically provide
them a better experience a more unified
experience across multiple plot maybe a
web and a mobile platform
health care and life sciences you know
basically how does the drug interact
with other drugs and then the one I
mentioned earlier you know which is the
most common case common career path to
get some myself to being CEO of a
company so what sort of industries use
graph this is by no means a definitive
list of either industries or how the
graphs are used inside those industries
but you know somewhere like that this is
an example of some of the ways in which
people use it some of the ways we've
worked with our customers in these areas
you know software companies they deal
with Knox in data management and that's
really nothing but a giant graph of how
you you know how everything how all your
networks are connected together social
networks are an obvious one you know
Facebook your LinkedIn things like that
one that actually kind of surprised me
when we first came across this as cases
like identity and access management you
know something like what Active
Directory does in a Windows world is a
real it really comes down to being a
graph problem because you are in groups
a B and C and in Group A your admin and
Group B you only have read-only access
group C you only have you know maybe you
have readwrite access and Group C has
access to a folder that group a has
access to and Group B has access to and
if sub files inside those what actual
access do you have to a file is really
basically a gigantic graph to find out
what you know all the different
permutations you have to get to your eye
you know to actually have access to that
end piece of data financial services you
know fraud prevention is probably the
most common one you hear in this you
know in the in the financial services
but you know there's also they do social
marketing they do impact analysis and
actually do sentiment analysis they're
there you know there are financial
services companies out there that are
reading your Twitter feed and your
Facebook posts and finding out what you
think about different companies because
what you think about different companies
affects how much or affects whether
their stock goes up or down that day
sometimes
so there's companies out there doing
stuff like that you know
telecommunications network management
much similar to software companies
master data management geospatial search
there's telecommunications companies out
there that basically are tracking you
know basically obviously they're
tracking where you're using your cell
phone and they're trying to basically
group to get you know cluster together
groups of people into to see maybe that
you're you maybe you and all your
friends went to dinner at the same time
at the same place for roughly the same
amount of time they're trying to find
this information out about you so they
can better market to you you know web
social and recruiting you know social
graphs knowledge graphs sentiment
analysis yet again probably one of the
more up-and-coming places as better
using graphs or things like healthcare
and life sciences you know they're
looking for drug interactions you know
looking for different things about gene
sequencing now you know they're looking
for impact analysis on treatment and
care there are any questions on some of
the use cases before we move on
okay the next thing we're going to talk
a bit about is the graph ecosystem
that's out there so first off what is a
graph database and yeah I know there's a
couple of you that have used graph
databases anyone else use any other know
sequels sort of databases or as most
people coming from the relational oil
okay well the graph graph databases are
a type of no sequel datastore they store
data based on graph concepts so you know
vertex is edges and properties there's
several different types out there that
we'll talk a bit about here in a moment
specifically the ones that are out there
already F triple stores property graph
models and what I tend to call
processing frameworks and what graph
databases do is they really help you
assess it's efficiently and effectively
navigate connected data you know data
that's highly connected with one another
so a little you know base of database
types so what you'll see on the screen
here is basically the different types of
but the five basic types of data stores
that are out there and how they each
handle increasing data complexity I mean
the simplest ones out there are things
like key value stores you know key value
stores or something like a dynamodb from
AWS or reddish and they store very
simple data they store a key value pair
of data you want to get a little more
have your data has a little bit more
complexity to it and stores more than
just one value to a key you get
something like a column family store you
know it allows you to store basically
single rows of data but those rows are
not don't have relationships to other
rows I don't have explicit relationships
to other rows I should say this is
something like a patchy Cassandra patchy
HBase you get a little more you know you
get data that it's a little more has a
little more relation a little more
complexity to it and when I'm talking
about complexity here what I'm really
referring to is basically the data is
related to one another and how those
relationships are manifested themselves
from the datastore
so you get something like a document
data store well you know a document data
store the the documents themselves are
pretty atomic units of information but
inside them they can have highly nested
relations of data you know something
like MongoDB or CouchDB or pretty good
examples of dyeing are pretty common key
examples of document data stores guess
the most a lot of people here have
probably used one or the other of those
and then there's the one that we're all
familiar with relational databases you
know relational databases are good it's
they're a good at storing relational
data so what they're built on you know
they have you know tables that have you
know Bob foreign keys to other table to
have foreign keys to other tables and
you can build out a hierarchy of data
there you know these are your Oracle is
your sequel servers your Postgres is
your my sequel things of that nature and
then for even more complex data that
doesn't fit in your relational database
you have graph databases two of the most
common ones out there for JJ and data
stacks enterprise graph those are the
two that we work with the most there's
many more out there else you'll see here
in a moment but as I mentioned earlier
the real big difference between a
relational database and a graph database
is that in a graph database the
relationships are also first class and
it is in your system and those
relationships can can store properties
against them one other thing to note is
that the data that graph databases are
the fastest-growing type of data store
out there at the moment since this is
started in January 2013 until this
January they've got at almost a 600
percent growth in so this comes from a I
don't know if any you know DBA engines
calm but if you don't it's actually a
very good site to that will kind of give
us a base comparison of different types
of data stores out there so just you
know this is part of the reason why I
wanted to come and do this talk was the
fact that this is a very fast-growing
area and it's something that you guys
will probably run into as or at least
might want to think about using in some
of the projects as you're coming up or
that are coming up for you
so the first differentiation I'm going
to make in the types of graph databases
is the difference between a database and
a framework a graph database is
basically built you know one of the
difference between the database and
framework is that databases will run
real time queries the hand some of them
can handle both transactional and
analytical type workloads you know and
they persist the data themselves they
tend to have note they'll have no
scaling feature and no sequel features
like scaling and high availability
whereas frameworks really are built to
work on humongous data loads and by
humongous data loads I'm talking about
data loads that tend to not fit don't
even necessarily fit in the memory of
the servers that they're running on
they're built for OLAP workloads and
they use another method underneath them
to actually persist the data it's often
something like a Hadoop cluster the way
I think of this is basically a framework
essentially as a library that sits on
top of something else to run your graph
data on so you have to sit there you'll
have to load your data into that graph
framework you have to run your graph
queries and you'll have to persist your
data out something else
a database itself is just like a sequel
database it handles both not only the DB
query of the data but also the
persisting of the data back so some of
the common graph processing frameworks
out there if you get into this space or
something like Apache giraffe I'm not
quite sure how that's supposed to be
dropped but that's what it is that is
that you know so you have something like
Apache giraffe which is built on top of
Hadoop that's where it runs first
persistence layer you have something
like graphics which is actually part of
the Apache spark project then you have
things like Oracle things you know which
is obviously built on top of Oracle
you'll have things like sync span graph
base info grid and this little guy here
is actually apache hama one interesting
one to note here is the apache tinker
pop project so the apache tinker pop
project is made up of a couple of
different parts
it's in and of itself it's a graph
processing framework
but that graph crossings scene framework
actually specifies a query language
associated with called gremlin which
we'll talk about here in a little bit
but that as well as the query language
it basically also specifies an interface
in a graph engine that are used by some
of the databases will talk in a about
here in a moment so it's kind of a very
[Music]
it's a complete you know it's kind of
has a lots of its hands in a lots of
different pieces of the graph database
world probably more than anything else
but in and of itself you can actually
just use it as a graph processing
framework so the next kind of
differentiation I made in just to be
honest these differentiations are semi
arbitrary on my part they're not really
arbitrary against they are sort of
there's some logic behind it
but other people might group these
slightly differently but the next one
I'm gonna talk about is basically the
two types of graph databases they're out
there one's called RDF or all building
core call the RDF triple stores they
work with a a subject predicate object
triple the entities that you store are
these triples this comes from a
background of the Semantic Web it has
well defined standards associated with
this and RDF databases are very
efficient at finding relationships
inside your data the other type is a
property model graph database this works
with the nodes edges and properties very
similar to what the first section where
I was showing talking about it has
separate entities for nodes and edges
and both the nodes nodes and edges can
have properties on them and what
property monographs databases are good
at is they're good at efficiently
traversing relationships in your data
and I'll show you an example of the
difference between these two
here in a moment but the biggest thing
to probably take away from this slide is
RDF databases are very good at finding
relationships in your data and property
model graph databases are very good at
reversing relationships in their data so
an example of RDF sort of an RDF
database what what sort of data you
would store in that is you know people
are people with a common parent or
siblings and a father is a parent so you
would put these rules in other way RDF
databases work is basically through an
inference engine so you basically put
these rules in as you've seen here the
next thing you'd put in is you'd put in
a couple of facts you put in the fact
that Mike is the father of John and that
Mike is the father of Steve ah what
would happen then is that that that
inference engine in the RDI database
would basically infer new facts about
your data based on the rules that you've
already entered so in this case it would
be able to infer that John and Steve are
siblings because you know you you know
they both have a father their father is
Mike and people with a common parent are
siblings property model graph databases
on the other hand would look more what
you have on the Left right up here but
this one over here don't know my life am
i right sorry
think what you would have to put in here
is you would have to put in the same
information you'd put in a node that is
you know that there's a person named
Mike a person in a person named John and
that there there's a relationship
between them of father of you would then
put in that there's a person named Steve
and the relationship would be father of
and here's where property model graphs
get a bit are definitely differ a little
bit than RDF sort of databases so you
know now you have an option you can
either if when you go to actually run
your traversal on this you can either
basically run a traversal that would say
okay you know give me you know for I
want to find you know for John I want to
find all the you know I want to find his
father and then I would find you know
who else he's the father of and be able
to in my app
location logic know that those two
people's are siblings or you could at
the time you put the data in put that
relationship in relationships in a
property model graph are basically
precomputed joins of your data so you
can either basically it works either way
you either basically navigate this
relationship inside your application
inside your traversal or you'd have to
pre-compute that joint ahead of time
there are any questions on this I know
this is a very kind of confusing sort of
concept yes
so so the question was in the RDF
database you basically define the you
know there you define the rules once and
you put the data and when the data comes
in you would you do it on the put in the
property monograph you only define
sibling of once well you would need to
define sibling of for each peep each
place you want to have that relationship
so this is where it's kind of an example
of how RDF databases are great at
finding information that you don't have
because it's able to basically infer
that this is a new relationship type
whereas property monographs are really
better at traversing that how those
relationships already exists so that you
know if you want to be efficient and you
want to find everyone that's a sibling
of somebody you need to put this sibling
of edge in for every person that's
assembling them you know maybe there's
John Steve Mike Tom Bill James who might
have a lot of kids what can I say oh you
would want to put the sibling of an edge
in for each of this that that answer
your question okay so what are some
common property monographs databases you
know the probably the most common one
out there right now is me or 4j it's
definitely the probably it's definitely
the industry leader in this space it's
what the two people in this room have
used it's it's probably the easiest to
get started with um then you move on
something like data stacks Enterprise
graphs this is a very built to basically
scale to larger data sizes it's built on
top of basically date stack Enterprise
if any of you're familiar with that um
well then you have one called orient DB
orient DB is actually you'll see it
again later because it's not only a
property monograph database but a multi
model graph database which I'll talk
about here in a moment but these three
that you see across the top here are
commercial commercial licensed products
they each have like a community version
essentially that you could you can try
out for free the bottom two here are
first one you'll see is called Janus
graph which is actually
new one on the market it's actually a
fork of an old one of an old of a
database that's been around for a while
called titan' this is actually very new
in as I think was last Thursday this was
announced as part of the Linux
Foundation so it's an open source
project run by the Linux Foundation
actually the company I work for Spiro is
one of the key members in there along
with people like Google Hortonworks
and IBM so that's our a little shout-out
to that one while I was here and then
there's another very interesting one as
I believe then we see there an alpha or
beta called DeGraff that's built to do a
highly distributed model of graph
databases of property model graph
databases the next this slide it
basically shows you some of the common
RDF data stores that are out there in
this slide you know you have ones like
star dog Allegra Graf blaze graph and on
to text of these the only one that has
any sort of open source option with it
is blaze graph all of the rest of them
are commercial license then you kind of
get into the middle ground of these ones
we call called multi model data stores
you have ones so basically what these
are or these are essentially I think of
them is basically a framework you know
graph crossing between framework on top
of another no sequel data store note
another type of data store but they both
come together in one package so for
example something like an orient DB you
can store not only unstructured data in
the form of documents in it but you can
store graph data under the covers it's a
document data store with a graph layer
on top of it but they expose both of
them to you which can be very useful
depending on what you're trying to
actually accomplish if you want to
accomplish if you have a use case where
you have where you want to use a multi
model sort of approach maybe you have a
bunch of unstructured data you want to
store but you want to store the
relationships between those data inside
of graphs something like an orient DB
would be great for that
you know if any of you familiar with
elasticsearch but it's the same sort of
thing they
recently released a graph model on top
of a graph framework on top but on top
of their product but be combed as part
of their product so like I said it's
kind of a it's a middle ground between
the two and then you know you have s AP
Hana Arango DB and virtuoso this
everything I'm showing up here in all
these slides there's there's more of
these types out there than I have on
these slides I just tried to show a
representative sample of some of the
more common ones so before we go on and
on the ecosystem of echo system
questions out there okay so your data
isn't in graph what do you do with it
now well the first thing you're going to
probably want to do is query your data
out what I'm showing here are really
there each of the data stores we showed
tend to have their own proprietary query
language a lot of times there's some
sequel like query language sometimes
it's almost exactly the same as sequel
what I'm showing here is basically the
only the standard or open source
languages that are here that are
implemented by multiple different
products um so the easiest one here is
down here with RDF databases there's a
w3c standard called Sparkle pretty much
any of the RDF databases out there will
implement at least some version of
sparkle some are more compatible than
others just like you know every other
standard after an Oracle I'll pair at
the top is where it definitely gets a
little bit more complex so the first one
you see here is what's called the open
cypher project cypher is the native
grass language that was developed by
neo4j I think was a little over a year
ago they they basically opened the
specifications for cypher and a project
called open cypher for other database
vendors to implement them a version of
cypher for them for their own language
cypher is a very declarative language
that's reminiscent of sequel I'll show
you some
examples here in a second and this
currently I believe has somewhere around
ten implementations of which they
believe for go against databases don't
don't quote me on those numbers because
yet again the numbers are changing all
the time but gives you a rough idea how
opted it how well adopted it is the next
one you'll see here with the cute little
green guy is Kremlin this is the query
language that specified as part of the
apache tinker pop project i talked about
before and it takes a more traversal
based approach to be basically to your
syntax and it currently has basically
seventeen plus implementations somewhere
along that the last one you'll see here
is actually graph QL graph QL was
basically developed by Facebook and it's
different from these other two in as
much as it's really a JSON based query
language that's for your API you'll
understand a little more what I mean
here in a second when I show you an
example but it's it's a bit of a
different beast than these other two
which are kind of more like comparable
what sequel would be for the relational
databases
so for these property model queries this
is the basic property model we're going
to work against pretty basic we're going
to do a small part of it but basically
you know we're what we're worried about
here is we're going to have a we want to
find all the people who acted in a film
that was directed by JJ Abrams so
basically we're going to basically come
from this person you know we're going to
find the person whose name is JJ Abrams
then we're going to follow this directed
in edge to the movie and then we're
going to follow this acted in edge back
to all the people that acted in movies
that he directed so the first way we're
going to look at is the open cipher
query um as you can see basically pretty
easily to read these sort of queries you
know things to note about cipher is
basically what you'll end up with is
basically the bright the round brackets
are the different types of nodes you're
looking for and the square brackets are
the edges and what you'll see is
actually the square brackets
have dashes and greater than our lesson
signs in front of them to basically
indicate the edge that that direction is
that you're traversing out that
direction so the next one is gremlin
gremlin is as you can see is a bit
different than the open-open cipher in
as much as what you're doing here is
your is your basically the way I think
about it is I'm actually this is I'm
telling it exactly how I want it to walk
through my graph in order to get the
information I'm looking for
so basically the way this works so givi
for those of you not familiar is
basically the way you say give me all of
all the vertices in my graph I want to
you know I want to find a person edge
our person node that has a name of JJ
Abrams and then once you follow the
outwards directed edge called directed
in then I want to so that would take us
to the movie vertice and then I want to
go back an inward directed edge called
accented acted in to get back to the
people this dot next is actually a very
specific thing to gremlin that said
basically it's lazily evaluated and
until you put something on there to
force it to be evaluated it won't
actually print anything out that that
dot next will actually force it to print
out all your results so as you can see
these are very similar yet different to
one another but when you look at grass
QL ye as you can see it's very familiar
if you used to doing something like rest
calls but it doesn't really look or map
directly or as easily to gremlin or open
Schaefer what it's doing here is
basically saying for I have I want to
find a person who has a name of JJ
Abrams then I want to go out the
directed that actually should say
directed in that was my bad
you know I want to find all the things
he directed in and then all the people
that acted in those and returned the
name and I said you know this is a very
you know it was a standard per dude by
Facebook I always think of these is very
useful if you're looking at build
rest endpoints because who wants to send
this sort of query across a rest
endpoint there were any questions on
this before I go on so the next thing is
how do you visualize your data you know
you know for visualizing your data
there's there's a lot of off-the-shelf
products something here like link
curious Enterprise is actually a very
powerful tool for doing some
visualization of your data something
like T line that's probably one of the
leaders in actually basically like web
web toolkits to work against your data
if you want to do a lot of different
customization something like a d3 is
very useful where this starts to get
very interesting is if you have a
geospatial products problem a lot of
times what we find is that the problems
we're working with end up having a
geospatial aspect with to them as well
not only do I want to know how things
were connected I want to know where they
were at at the times that that certain
event happens especially if you're
thinking like in the IOT space so these
are just some of the tools out there but
what can you kind of do with it so these
are some basically some screens of
things that we have worked on one and
the my UX colleagues would would harass
me if I didn't basically say that just
because it's a graph piece of data you
know just because the underlying data is
a graph doesn't mean you need to show
just as no charts you know in a case of
here you know this was an IOT sort of
demo you know where you were following
trucks and following sensors that makes
sense to basically kind of almost show
that as a no chart of the flow of where
it's going but over here this is a
healthcare app the graph data underneath
the data underneath it may be stored in
a graph but that's not how the end users
are thinking about it and then users
shouldn't know or necessarily care that
the data is being stored as a graph so
you know applying good UX principles to
these sorts of things are
are really important in order to
basically get the best information out
of it
you know good examples of this are
something like a LinkedIn or Facebook or
you know they don't show you that the
graph of how your friends how they got
front - the friend you may know they
just show you a list of people that you
may know but it's being powered under
the covers Biograph you know Amazon
recommendations are the same sort of way
you people who bought this off about
that now let's be empowered by a graph
at some level but they're not telling
you that it's powered by graph they're
just showing you the output in a way
that's easily consumed by the user so
the last photo section here is why
should you care about it well we're
going to look at a basic product
recommendation engine here you know I
want to find all the products that I
have purchased find me all the products
I haven't purchased but we're purchased
by customers who purchased other things
I bought pretty simple are pretty common
I want our need for a you know any sort
of e-commerce site is kind of to power
out your product recommendation
well here's roughly the sequel it takes
to do that
you know the actual specifics don't
matter here I'll share the slides with
you later if anybody wants but here's
the corresponding cipher and gremlin to
answer that same query you know for you
know if you look at the gremlin or the
cipher it's about takes these three
lines to answer what takes pretty much
all the way down to this group by to get
to the same sort of answer you know and
the gremlin takes a little bit more than
that but you know in general you're
talking you know for you know three or
four lines versus probably 15 to get
your answer
performance I mean obviously performance
you're going to be very different
depending on what you're doing but I
would not wreck
it's not going to be super performant uh
whereas the sights on the gremlin will
be because that's what they're optimized
for so the next use case is basically to
find an org chart you know I want to
find out the employee all the employees
who their supervisor is and where they
live inside the organization um you know
basically build out a simple org chart
well to do that in the sequel you
essentially have to end you end up
having to build this recursive recursive
function to basically pull the
information out you know it takes all
the way till down here these you know
probably twelve lines of code to get to
basically the just the rough data before
you actually can even pull it out well
here is the decipher to do it basically
a decipher to do all of these twelve
lines is pretty much this first line
will return you all the data after that
it's actually just formatting the data
the way you want to actually pull it
back out in Gremlin it basically takes
about the line and a half to do the same
sort of thing you know here's you know
kind of shows you how you know something
like this is brought is more performant
or can be more performant and certainly
easier to maintain for these sorts of
queries so how do you know if you need a
graph this is another question we get
all the time well if you can answer yes
to any of these sorts of questions then
you might have a problem that is worthy
of a that would be worthwhile to take a
look at using a graph database for you
know do you have queries with multiple
joins and unions of data you have
recursive common table expressions is
the performance of your joins or common
table expressions poor and can't be
increased by other means or you know by
standard traditional relational database
techniques is the structure of your data
continuously evolving one of the things
I hadn't touched on much here is the
fact that graph databases tend to be
very good at allowing for evolving
flexible schemas you know if you want to
add a new relationship type to your
graph you just
relationship-type Geograph you don't
need to go in change tables add default
values things like all those things you
end up having to do in a relational
database to make that two basic we'd
make it a you know work is your domain
that you're working in a natural fit for
them you know are you storing IT
dependencies are you doing network
management are you doing relationships
between people or any of those sort of
things we talked about in the use cases
and the one that probably sticks with me
more than anything else is are you
dealing with the connections between
things more often than you're dealing
with the things themselves
do you really is what you're really
trying to care about housing is how the
things are connected together more than
what is connected together that's a
really strong indicator to myself that
you know you might want to look at using
a graph database so if you're actually
interested in getting started if you go
to this website we actually have theirs
getting started with graph link and it
basically provides a long list of just
different resources that you can go out
to get started with graph including
links to pretty much all of the data
stores we talked about up here at least
the versions that you can download for
free their tutorials their getting
started pages things like that and if
anyone's interested and once the slide
deck is come see me after this and I can
send it to you so you can get some of
these addresses or whatever so I guess
they're any questions
so the question was do these graph
databases allow you to partition data to
sort across multiple nodes in sort of a
cluster yeah and allow you to do queries
on the partitioned data the answer to
that question is it depends on which
graph data story you're looking at I'm
not as familiar with a lot of the RDF
one so I can't answer to those
specifically as much but on the property
grab model graph database side yes they
can if you look at something like like
data sacks Enterprise is basically I
don't know if you guys are familiar with
Apache Cassandra at all it's built on a
clustering technology by default and
data stacks enterprise graph is built on
top of that so it's absolutely by
default those are partitioned if you're
looking at something like neo4j if you
go to their Enterprise Edition and their
most recent release they actually added
causal clustering to their to their
graphs databases if you look at
something like an orient DB they have
the ability to partition that data out
as well using their own internal
mechanisms so yes each of them have it
and each of them do it in a different
way hey that answer your question
any other questions
so the question was are people using
these as systems of record or as a
primary data store or are they using
them as secondary data store the answer
to that is both it depends on what the
specific use case is I've worked with
customers where they basically migrated
other paths or in the process of
migrating all their data to be stored
inside a graph as the system of record
I've also worked with customers where
this is used as a a secondary system a
lot of times especially if they want to
if they have a small part of their
application or their it's a small part
of the system where they have a very
graph based problem that they want to
solve in a small area you know they may
keep their large Oracle installation or
sequel server installation to be the
system of record and then transfer the
data into this either in batches or
continuously to handle those sorts of
dependency queries or whatever it is
they're trying to actually pull out that
is better solved in a graph
any that eye prote that combined an RDF
with the property database actually a
there's several of them that will allow
you to traverse them as both I believe
actually Oracle does this a star dog I
believe does that as well and ice plays
grass I believe also will allow you to
basically do either RDF or property
graph to ruffles of them I can't say
I've done anything with those in that
specific use case so I don't have any
personal experience with it
unfortunately but I believe they both a
lot but those ones I believe allow you
to do it in both ways
okay that's it thank you guys very much
[Applause]